we were talking earlier about the stunts
that you do I am a massive fan of the
mission impossible franchise and my son
and I it's a way like my son and I have
bonded and why I was telling you this
earlier we watched them together and we
have a deal that whenever an intense
fight scene breaks out I attack my son
and it's and it's if he gets hurt he
loves that he's hurt he's three months
old yeah but you know what I would I
think no one can quite process is the
stunts that you do you climbed Burj
Khalifa I believe you held your breath
for six and a half minutes underwater
for one you hung off the side of an
Airbus a400m you--every of CGI and would
you ever want to explore it or is it
important to you to really do this you
know even if you look back in my first
films taps you know I trained and
studied to become military kind of guy I
even it's a little kid I did stunts you
know I already when you were a kid one
yeah I used to write skits to make my
family laugh as I told you and I I just
loved climbing the tallest trees on
windy days and kind of going back and I
did I was that kid that would jump off
the roof right you know doing flips
right I mean I'm saying right I was not
that kid I stayed inside and wrote in my
pink diary but anyway but yeah but your
jumping off roofs did you I got hurt oh
yeah I broke
I broke bones my nose and my teeth and
and then I started making movies and I
was actually doing taps and there was
stunt guys on there I was like you guys
there's a place you learn how to do this
and for me it's it's about storytelling
and I I grew up watching you know
Charlie Chaplin Buster Keaton Harold
Lloyd you know Abbott Costello
you know these they're they're kind of
work like they did the classics and they
they maybe laugh and they had tension so
these things that I want to I want to
really build stories around it that's
why I started producing mission
Impossibles when when and this also
relates to what we're about to try to
put the audience in the seat of those
characters well that's what happens is
when you're doing those stunts it's
quite clean
you're always you always stood in such a
way that it's very clear it's you and
that you're on the side of that airplane
and there been times where you've been
hurt almost killed and it makes me think
are you a bit of a you a bit addicted to
the adrenaline of it all do you ever
think that is that you're that you you
need that in your life do you know what
I mean no I can help you talk is it I'm
just wondering what's a doubt like when
you look at your schedule and usually
your schedule because you make some of
these films is you know attach yourself
to side of airplane get on motorcycle
and jump off Empire State Building and
then you look at when I saw that
airplane the night before yeah it was a
great idea in location scout or kind of
figured everything out how to do it and
I'll never forget the night before it
was dark it was lit from underneath it
looked like a monster and I thought
maybe this wasn't such a good idea so
what's it like for you when you look at
your schedule in the morning and it's
there's nothing like that it just says
make poached eggs and then nap you know
do you feel a little disappointed when
there's none of that in your life on
that day yeah I do actually
I mean I it's usually my day isn't like
that actually my day is always usually I
mean I just finished Top Gun we are
filming all this stuff in the f8
thank you
no they look exactly like you and goose
they really do and now I'm prepping for
Mission Possible we're gonna shoot to
Mission Possible you in a row
[Applause]